[Music]
you always were when you do a special
you always wear a leather jackets kind
of your thing is it the same leather
jacket every time basically the same
jacket and then I trained I've had like
4050 leather jackets and I sweat through
them onstage like Mitchell II through
the leather and they smell disgusting
and so what I do is I normally funny
it's a fact yeah they're probably
wondering why you keep doing it yeah so
I just buy another Jack and get rid of a
jacket by today dr. Drew came to me this
is my my Hollywood friends dr. drew yeah
yeah good guy he's a shy fella doesn't
want to be on TV too much keeps to
himself dr. drew comes to me and he said
I were having a charity auction and
we're gonna auction off some clothing
that celebrities having there's like a
pair of Elton John shoes and my carry
goes something and everyone signs it
because can you give anything so I gave
one of my leather jackets that was off
one of my specials I signed the inside
of it and I also gave the DVD of the
special I was wearing the jacket and
that was really nice that's a nice thing
but then I got obsessed and I kept on
checking the online auction every day
and it just wasn't getting bid on so I
started bidding for it to put the price
up and then it got to a stage where I
had paid more for the jacket than it was
going for in the celebrity auction so I
bought the thing back I gave the money
I've still got the jacket
[Applause]
that deserves a testicle yeah Morrissey
but first thing I did a comeback stage
and Chris Hardwick's fiance says would
you like a dick I'm like you do yeah
yeah she's got a go with it
you